Now let's work out
an example that
shows how to use the
pairwise independent sampling
theorem to actually do some
sampling and estimation.
So let's remember that
our basic theorem says
that if we have n independent
random variables--
pairwise independent, with
the same mean and variance--
and we look at their
average, the probability
that their average differs
from the mean by more than a
given tolerance delta is less
than or equal to this formula
here.
Which is the standard deviation
over delta squared times 1
over n.
Now we're just going to be
plugging into this formula,
but I want to state
it here for the record
to remember that this is the
pairwise independent sampling
theorem that we're given.
Which is, what we've
seen in general,
allows us to calculate
the degree of confidence
we can have, the probability
that we have given n
or the n that we need given
how confident we want to be.
So let's go ahead
and do the example.
And I want to think about what
is the possibility of swimming
in the Charles.
Now, Charles has
a coliform count.
Coliform are some rather
undesirable bacteria
that are associated
with fecal matter.
And we want to know whether it's
safe to swim in the Charles.
That's a Petri dish showing
a kind of sample of bacteria
that you might grow, cultured
to see what's going on.
The Environmental
Protection Agency
requires that the average CMD,
the coliform microbial density,
on the dish is less than 200.
And what we want
to do is figure out
whether, when we do a sample
of CMDs around the river,
and we get some numbers
out, whether, in fact, we
will conclude that the
average CMD is less than 200.
We need to convince
the EPA of that.
Now, we're never
going to be certain.
But what we're
going to do is take
32 measurements at random times
and locations around the river.
And we're going to collect
these 32 measurements of CMD.
And it's going to turn out
that, although a few of them
are over 200, the average
is well under 200.
The average of the 32 samples
that we've taken is 180.
And our task now is to convince
the Environmental Protection
Agency that, on the
basis of our data,
that the average in the whole
river is really less than 200.
Even though where
a couple of places
it was over 100, but
on average it was 180,
can we convince the EPA
that the actual average
is less than 200?
And so we're trying
to convince them
that our estimate
based on the sample
is within 20 of
the actual average.
We got 180, so if our estimate
is within 20 of the truth,
then in fact, the
average is less than 200.
Well how are we
going to do that?
Well, let's look
at the parameters
in the same pairwise
independent sampling theorem
and see what we have.
So c is the actual
average CMD in the river.
That's what we don't know.
We're trying to estimate it.
So our samples correspond
to a random variable.
We're taking a
measurement of the CMD
at random time and place.
And that defines a random
variable whose expectation
is the unknown city.
So we've defined, by
our sampling process,
a random variable with mean u.
In fact, we've done
it with 32 variables.
So n samples mean n mutually
independent random variables.
All with mean
equal to the number
that I'm trying to estimate.
And A n is the average
of the n CMD samples.
So we have an A32 that
we're trying to understand.
So here's the independent
sampling theorem formula.
And let's see what
I know already.
I'm going to plug in the knowns.
What I know is that n is
32, mu is the unknown, c,
that we're trying to estimate.
And the delta that
matters to us is 20.
Because we want to argue
that if our average of 180,
our measurement of 180,
was within 20 of the truth,
then in fact, we're under the
200 that the EPA specifies.
So let's plug in our
known parameters, 32 for n
and 20 for the tolerance.
And they plug in here.
And that leaves me with
the standard deviation,
which the formula requires
and I have to plug in.
And that is a problem,
because we don't know
what the standard deviation is.
Now, sometimes you
can kind of argue
that you can figure out what
the standard deviation is
because you have a theory of
what the random distribution is
of these measurements.
And therefore, you can calculate
what its standard deviation
should be.
Other times you
can actually take
a sample of the
deviation of your sample
and use that as an
estimate of the sample
of the actual
standard deviation.
But that's kind of circular,
and we're not going to go there.
But another way
to do it is to say
that if you had some bounds
on the maximum possible
discrepancy of
your measurements,
if you had done these kinds
of sampling testings of CMDs
for a long time and you
had never observed two that
were more than 50 apart,
then what you could argue
is that the range
of measurements
is going to be only 50.
So what we can do
is if we say that L
is the maximum possible
difference that we'll ever
measure among samples, that
in fact, what you can say
is that the worst possible
standard deviation when
your random variable is ranging
over an interval l is l over 2.
And you can check
that algebraically,
but for now let's just
take that as a fact.
If you know that
your measurements are
going to differ by at most
l between max and min,
the standard deviation
can't be more than l over 2.
And if we know that l is 50,
then I got a number finally
to plug in.
Because now I can
plug in 25 for sigma.
So let's do that.
And when I do that, I come
out with this calculation that
says that the probability
that my average,
minus c, was greater than
20, that my A32, which
we said was 180, was more
than 20 away from the truth
is less than 0.05.
Or, flipping it
around, the probability
that my average is
within 20 of the truth
is greater than 0.095.
And so we would like
to be able to say, now,
that the probability
that the unknown c is
the 180 that we measured
for A32, plus or minus 20,
is at least 95%.
That seems to be what
the theorem told us.
Let's go back.
The theorem says that
the probability that A32,
which we measured to be
180, minus c is less than
or equal to 20, is
greater than 0.95.
So we should go back
and tell the EPA
that the probability is
that c is less than 200
with probability 0.95.
And we'd be pretty
tempted to say that.
But it's not right.
It's technically the
wrong thing to say.
And why is that?
Well, it's an
important idea, which
is that we're talking
about something
other than probability here.
We're talking about
confidence, not probability.
And let's explain that
a little bit more.
Here's the issue.
The number c is a number
in the real world.
It's an actual physical
quantity which is
the average CMD in the river.
We don't know what it is.
But that does not make
it a random variable.
It is or it isn't within less
than 200 or more than 200
and so on.
What's going on is that we have
created a probabilistic model
of sampling that is designed to
have in our probabilistic model
this unknown constant.
There's nothing probabilistic
about the constant.
We've introduced the
probability by thinking
of our random sampling
as random variables.
We control the randomness.
We can't say that c is random.
Our measurements are random.
So the right thing we can say
is that the possible outcomes
of our sampling process
can persuasively be
modeled as a random variable.
So what we can say is
that the probability
that our sampling
process will yield
an average that's within
20 of the true average
is at least 0.95.
So that's a funny thing to say.
What you do is you go tell
the EPA that says, look.
We don't know what
the real average is.
But we have a process that
gets the right answer 95%
of the time to within
plus or minus 20.
And we measured it.
And our process that we
right 95% of the time
came in with an answer that
said it's less than 200.
OK?
Now that's the
right thing to say.
That's the truth.
We're making a
probabilistic statement
about the general properties
of our sampling process,
and saying, OK.
Our sampling process
is usually right.
The sampling process
said less than 200.
So we think that's
probably right.
But we can't say it is
right, and we can't even
say it's right with
any probability.
It's just the way that our
mostly reliable process
yielded an answer.
And that's an important
idea to distinguish.
So it's our estimate that that's
correct with probability 0.95.
Now this is a long
thing to say to the EPA.
And what we'd like to
go back is language
that says that we think
that the real average, c, is
within 20 of 180 is
probably within 20 of 180.
Because that's what
our tests seem to say.
But we're not allowed to
talk about the probability
that c has some value or other.
So instead we
summarize the story
about how we measured c using
a probabilistic process that's
right 95% of the
time by saying that c
is 180 plus or minus 20 at
the 95% confidence level.
And that is that's
a shorthand way
of saying we've got this
process that we believe
in that measured
this unknown quantity
and told us what it was.
So the moral here that we'll
wrap up this little video with
is that when you're told
that some fact holds
at a high confidence
level because
of some tester, or some random
experiment, or some pollster,
you have to remember
that what that implies
is that somebody designed
a random experiment to try
to get an estimate of reality.
And you can always question
whether you believe
in that random experiment.
It's important to
understand that there
is some random
experiment back there.
And you should be
wondering about what is it?
And do I believe in it?
And even more important
question to ask
is why are you hearing about
this particular experiment?
How many other experiments
were tried and not reported?
The point is that
people can perform
various kinds of tests at the
95% or higher confidence level.
But when the tests don't come
up with an interesting result,
they don't bother to publish
them or announce them.
And of course, when they come up
with a surprising result which
is going to be wrong
one out of 20 times,
those are the results
that they publish
and submit and advertise.
Because they sound good.
In fact, the major drug
company Glaxo SmithKline,
after paying $3 billion
as a judgment against them
in 2012 for suppressing
the negative results
of clinical trials,
just agreed to now
make public in February 2013
all of the clinical trials
that they perform.
So that you're not
just learning about
the cherry picked
positive results,
but about the
negative ones as well.
And in fact, [AUDIO OUT[
to get this point home,
you might want to look
at the cartoon at XKCD,
which explains how it is that
when there's a problem with
green jelly beans at the
95% confidence level.